the most important piece of what
happened a year and a half ago is why
did twitter especially facebook did it
too but why did twitter
ban the new york post account and
suspend people for talking about this
how did that meeting happen at twitter
who was in charge was there a boardroom
meeting was there a policy meeting was
there a lawyer's meeting who was in
charge of that meeting and did those
people what was the information they
used to decide to ban and suspend people
for posting something that now turns out
to be true did those people have any
connection to the democrats did they
have any connection to the biden
campaign like what was the policy if we
don't find that out we'll never get to
the truth and unfortunately i don't
think we'll find that out but it just
does tell you if you're on social media
we are playing a fixed game we are all
playing a fixed game where they can
control the information they can control
the algorithms and who sees what and
when they see it and what's true and
what's information misinformation and
everything else here's uh
chronic misinformation specialist and
liar in chief jen sake on the hunter
biden report
the new york times has authenticated
emails that appear to have come from a
laptop abandoned by hunter biden in
delaware
the president previously said that the
new york post story about this was a
bunch of garbage and that it was a
russian plant does he stand by that
assessment i appointed the department of
justice and also to hunter biden's
representatives he doesn't work in the
government go ahead
jen
i actually like what you did there did
you just uh refer the journalists to the
department of justice about this
situation because i don't know how
corrupt they are at this point i don't
know if there's anything left over there
but maybe they should be looking into it
because you know you just got caught
lady
here's joe biden a little bit before the
election
saying how the whole thing is nonsense
and i really really want you to listen
to it because it's not just that he says
it's nonsense but guess who he blames
you're not going to believe it so what
about the americans who really today
only want me to ask you about hunter
biden's laptop how are you going to get
them
to see
that you are fighting for them when
they're so against you
there's nothing to any of that
nothing to that it's all a smear
every major outfit every serious
investigator has pointed out
that this is a smear
this is classic trump
we have four days left and all of a
sudden there's a laptop and
you may recall there's also talk about
four months before there was a similar
thing that somebody had allegedly
there's overwhelming evidence that from
the intelligence community that the
russians are engaged i mean look this is
my son's an honorable man
and all the investigations that were
done around the issue of what was going
on in ukraine if you notice
every one of the major people who work
for trump
during the impeachment went under oath
and under oath said biden did his job
no law was providing this biden did his
job hunter biden broke no laws that was
the testimony
their testimony from republicans and
intelligence community people
god he is a mind
muddled [ __ ] he really is and that's a
depressing statement to say i wish the
president of the united states even if
he had policies that i did not this that
i did not agree with i wish
that he was in better shape than that
man but i want to point out to a couple
things he said there first of you know
nothing here is true it's all a smear
blah blah blah every major outlet and
our intelligence services are saying
that well that's the problem that's the
problem because there seems to be
collusion between our intelligence
services and the experts and then
mainstream media they just parrot all
the stuff it's it's a shell game it's a
it's a funneling of lies through the
entire system so yes you're right about
that joe but that's the problem in the
first place and then of course he blames
trump as if trump had something to do
with this that trump somehow created
this laptop situation and the emails and
all that and uh russians are engaged ah
yes so are you saying russians meddled
with the election and tried to get trump
elected because if you did
say that and even if it didn't come to
pass wouldn't you be doing something
about that right now
god they lie about everything i mean
this is close to impeachment level stuff
right so that him what he just said
there i mean basically blaming trump
lying about the laptop
i mean i get it that it was done before
he was president but the whole
presidency now seems to be based on a
lie
the whole presidency seems to be based
on a lie on top of the fact that the
presidency in the year plus
of his administration has been a
horrific disaster
by far the worst in my lifetime and i
think many people could argue this might
be the worst administration
in american history in american history
this might be worse than carter this
might be worse than some of the others a
long time back
everything seems to be collapsing they
seem to be intentionally destroying the
the system and they seem to want to
usher in their great reset their new
world order whatever it is but please
show me something that joe biden is
doing that is pro america that that is
helping ordinary americans